>>> A NEW REPORT FINDS ONE-HALF
OF COVID DEATHS COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED IF THE VACCINATION
RATE HAD REACHED 100%.
THAT'S ABOUT 319,000 LIVES LOST.
THE FINDINGS COME FROM
RESEARCHERS AT BROWN UNIVERSITY.
BILL GATES WARNED OF THE THREAT
MORE THAN SEVEN YEARS AGO DURING
THE EBOLA OUTBREAK.
HE LOOKS AT WHAT WENT WRONG IN
THE COVID RESPONSE AND THE
LESSONS THAT CAN BE APPLIED
GOING FORWARD.
PLEASE WELCOME BILL GATES.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
>> GREAT TO TALK TO YOU.
>> WE BOTH MANAGED TO GO FOR
MORE THAN TWO YEARS COVID FREE
BEFORE CATCHING IT.
I GOT IT ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO.
ON TUESDAY YOU TWEETED YOU
TESTED POSITIVE AND EXPERIENCING
MILD SYMPTOMS.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'M VERY LUCKY.
I CAUGHT IT EARLY.
I HAD -- I HAVEN'T HAD SERIOUS
SYMPTOMS AT ALL.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE WARNED OR
MARKED THE MILESTONE YESTERDAY
OF A MILLION COVID DEATHS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
BACK WHEN THIS STARTED, WHEN YOU
AND I FIRST STARTED SPEAKING
ABOUT THIS, DID YOU THINK IT
COULD COME TO THIS, A MILLION
DEATHS?
>> WE KNEW THAT THERE WAS A LOT
WE DIDN'T KNOW.
A MILLION WOULD HAVE BEEN AT THE
VERY HIGH END.
WE UNDERSTAND ESTIMATED THE NEW
VARIANTS WOULD BE SO
TRANSMISSIVE.
OMICRON IS VERY HARD TO BLOCK
THE TRANSMISSION.
THE VACCINES HAVE BEEN THE
MIRACLE BUT EVEN THERE THEY
DON'T BLOCK SOME AMOUNT OF
INFECTION.
I HAD FOUR VACCINES.
THE LAST ONE JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO.
YOU GET THESE BREAKTHROUGH
INFECTIONS THAT MEANS WE STILL
HAVE WILL THE OF TRANSMISSION.
MILLIONS QUITE HORRIFIC.
>> YOU HAD YOUR TWO VACCINATIONS
AND THEN TWO BOOSTER SHOTS, IS
THAT RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
FOR PEOPLE OVER 50 OR 60, THEY
WILL PROBABLY HAVE TO BE BOOSTED
EVERY SIX MONTHS UNTIL WE GET
EVEN BETTER TRYING THE FIGURE
THIS OUT MYSELF, WHEN DO YOU GET
BOOSTED AGAIN?
NOW THAT YOU'VE HAD IT.
YOU AND I HAD IT AROUND THE SAME
TIME.
I'VE ONLY GOTTEN THREE SHOTS
TOTAL.
ONLY BEEN BOOSTED ONCE.
I GUESS WE HAVE IMMUNITY FOR A
WHILE.
WHEN DID YOU DECIDE TO GET
BOOSTED AGAIN?
>> TO BE SAFE EVERY SIX MONTHS I
WILL PROBABLY BE VACCINATED.
AS WE GET MORE DATA, THEY MIGHT
MAKE THAT SHORTER FOR PEOPLE 60
OR OVER 70 WHERE THE DURATION
SEEMS TO BE A BIT LOWER.
>> YOU AND I HAVE TRIED TO -- I
TRIED TO ASK YOU ABOUT WHAT THE
FUTURE LOOKS LIKE EVERY TIME
I'VE TALKED TO YOU.
OBVIOUSLY, IT'S HARD THING TO
KNOW.
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW NOW WITH ALL
THESE VARIANTS THAT SEEM TO
EMERGE PRETTY REGULARLY, IS THE
FUTURE FOR MUCH OF THE REST THIS
IS THIS THING THAT EXISTS.
WE JUST HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT.
IS THAT WHAT THE FUTURE OF
CORONAVIRUS CORONAVIRUS IS.
?
>> WE PROBABLY WON'T HAVE BETTER
VACCINES.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE SHOULD
INVEST IN TO REALLY FINISH THIS
OFFER IS LONGER DURATION,
LIFELONG DURATION VACCINES
.
IT'S TOUGH VARIANT CAME ALONG
AND WE DON'T KNOW THE ODDS OF
THAT.
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF HEARING
ABOUT THIS PANDEMIC AND WE NEED
TO KEEP REMINDING THEM ABOUT
STAYING UP THE DATE ON
VACCINATIONS.
>> HOW REAL IS THAT IDEA OF A
VACCINE THAT VACCINATED YOU FROM
ANY FUTURE CORONAVIRUS?
IS THE TECHNOLOGY THERE?
>> THE BREATH OF PROTECTION, WE
NODE TO WORK ON THAT.
THE DURATION AND BLOCKING THE
INFECTION.
WE HAVE A THREE CONSTRUCTS OF
EARLY STAGE THAT HAVE PROMISE
THERE.
THE VACCINES ARE GOOD ENOUGH WE
KEEP TAKING THOSE IN TERMS OF
SEVERE DISEASE AND DEATH.
YOU HAVE VERY GOOD PROTECTION.
I HOPE THE DURATION WOULD BE
LONGER BUT THE DATA COMING OUT
SAYS THAT IF YOU'RE OLDER, IT'S
NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
YOU NEED THE KEEP REVACCINATING.
>> DO YOU WORRY ABOUT THE LONG
COVID WITH THE INFECTION THAT
YOU GOT?
>> LONG COVID SCENARIO THERE'S A
LOT OF RESEARCH ON.
THERE'S A TON OF THINGS ABOUT
HEART OR DIABETES THAT PEOPLE
ARE WORRIED ABOUT THERE.
I SAY WE REALLY DON'T KNOW MUCH
BUT IT DOES LOOK LIKE IF YOU
HAVE A MILD CASE, WHICH I'M
LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE HAVING, THAT
THE LIKELIHOOD OF LONG COVID IS
VERY LOW.
AGAIN, IT'S A STRONG THING THAT
IF YOU DO GET COVID, GETTING
ACCESS TO ANTIVIRALS OR
ANTIBODIES AS FAST AS YOU CAN IS
WORTH IT.
>> ARE YOU STILL POSITIVE NOW?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> TODAY I HAD NUMBER OF
NEGATIVE TESTS.
I GOT THE MOST SENSITIVE PCR
TEST THAT I'LL GET LATER
TONIGHT.
LOOKS LIKE I'VE BEEN LUCKY WITH
A MILD CASE.
>> YOU SITE THE INCREDIBLE SPEED
TO WHICH THE VACCINE WAS
CREATED.
YOU RIGHTLY CHAMPION IT.
THERE'S THIS PARADOX THAT THE
SPEED IT WAS CREATED ALSO
INCREASED SOME HESITANCY AND I
GUESS AND HAS FUELED THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
IS IT POSSIBLE TO GET PAST THAT
AT THIS POINT?
DO YOU THINK PEOPLE'S IDEAS
ABOUT THE VACCINE HAVE ALREADY
BEEN BAKED IN?
>> THE HESITANCY DID GO DOWN.
INITIALLY IT WAS LIKE AT 60% OF
THE POPULATION.
AS THEY SAW FRIENDS GETTING
VACCINATE AND VERY RARE SIDE
EFFECTS AS THEY SAW THE FRIENDS
BEING PROTECTED AND THE PEOPLE
WITH SEVERE DISEASE WERE
OVERWHELMINGLY THE UNVACCINATED.
MOST PEOPLE CAME AROUND.
THE U.S. STILL HAS A LOWER FULL
BACK -- VACCINATION RATE.
ARE THE PEOPLE OPEN MINDED
BECAUSE IT'S TO THEIR BEN
FIT
AND THE PEOPLE AROUND THEM.
I'M SURPRISED THAT THE U.S. HAS
BEEN THIS TOUGH AND EVEN
SOMEWHAT -- WE NEED TO BE
CREATIVE AT HOW WE GET PEOPLE TO
SEE IT AND HEAR ABOUT PEOPLE
THEY KNOW THAT SUFFERED FROM NOT
FULLY PROTECTING THEMSELVES.
>> HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH
CONSPIRACY THEORIES?
PEOPLE BELIEVE YOU'RE TRACKING
PEOPLE THROUGH MICROCHIPS
INSERTED INTO THE VACCINE.
GIVEN WHAT YOU HAVE DONE TO HELP
DEAL AND SAVE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE'S LIVES AROUND THE WORLD
FOR VACCINATIONS, FOR POLIO,
NEARLY WIPING OUT POLIO.
HOW THE YOU DEAL WITH IT WHEN
PEOPLE HAVE THESE IDEA ABOUT
YOU?
>> SIMPLE EXPLANATIONS ARE FUN
TO CLICK ON AND THEY SEEM TO
SPREAD AND FILL SOME THERE MUST
BE RATHER THAN THIS COMPLEX
BIOLOGY, MAYBE THERE'S THIS BAD
PERSON BEHIND THIS